I hate going to bars.
*cheering*
You wait in line forever for an overpriced drink.
That will be $75.00.
Times 25.  Plus tax.  And Tip.
And of course there's always that one guy
who tries to neg you like he just took an online course
or read a book or something and now he's trying out his experiments.
You know I'm not really into Asians but...
...for you I'd make an exception.
Trimmed my pubes for nothing.
And no matter what, there is always such a long line
for the bathroom.  Okay?  Look at this line!
Why is there only one stall here?
*screaming*
There's always that one girl who can't handle her alcohol.
Is this the line for the bathroom?
No, you're lying down sweetie.
Mmhm.
Okay.
And if you're lucky, you just might meet this guy.
Hey, can I buy you a drink?
Sure.
Great.
And then maybe later we can both go to the abandoned
ravine and see how long we can hold each others
heads underwater.
I'd love to see what you look like without that dress on.
And without that skin on.
I'll get you that drink first.  We'll talk about the skin later?
No!
I'd really like to come back around to that skin.
Okay, I think one of us just crossed the line.
*screaming*
And of course finally there's always the person
who gets blackout drunk and doesn't remember
how much of an asshole they were being.
I'm Anna Akana you stay awesome--
*crash*
And, before I go, I do want to say
thank you to Mike and Megan from Catastrophic Creations.
As you may have noticed, my apartment is full of cat furniture.
I've got sisal poles, I've got raceway tracks, I've got an Indiana Jones bridge.
I've got all the stuff!
And that is from Catastrophic Creations.
They create functional yet really contemporary
and modern looking cat furniture to match the decor of my apartment.
And if you didn't know, I have 4 cats.
I have four cats!  So territory can be a little bit of an issue.
But with all the cat furniture they have their own little spaces.
And Congress, everyday after dinner, loves to run across the Indiana Jones bridge,
screaming for no apparent reason.
Probably like rejoicing that he had dinner.
So it's just the best so thank you so much
to Mike and Megan, I love you and I love your cats and love your cat furniture.
And if you're interested, adopt 2 cats
and I'll put a link to their Etsy shop in the description bar
so you can give them some fun raceway tracks
to just like run around with on their little paws.
And the sisal pole is great because, if you can see it right there,
that long pole right there,
they [the cats] scratch that instead of the couches.
So Brad don't get mad heehee.
I'll see you next Monday.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
It's back!